so i hope that makes sense um and what i
will do quickly is i will just ask you
to post in the chat if this was the way
that you did it or if you have some
other solution because i'm about to show
you a different way to do it which i
think is arguably a little more elegant
but it takes a bit more thinking even if
there are slightly less lines of working
can you just post in the chat for me um
you've got one of three options okay
either i solved it that way that was
just shown i solved it a different way
or
i didn't solve it like i was just a bit
confused and i couldn't quite get there
um can you let me know okay so i got a
couple of early votes thank you emmanuel
and angad
different similar thanks sasmit and
veren
i'll wait for a couple more responses
again it's actually really important to
me if you could not see and maybe i
didn't give you enough time but if you
couldn't see how because that's an
indicator for me that i should spend
more time we've got a few more lessons
still to revise and i'll spend i'll
invest some more time in vectors if it's
valuable
any other responses thanks charlie liam
and jun
that is most of us isn't it okay okay
fantastic all right
so
i'm interested by the uh i'm interested
by the balance it actually seems quite
um
even how many people did it this way
versus another way so i'm going to show
you one more um path which i think is
it's attractive because it it takes
advantage of of thinking and
understanding the proportions of the
question um but it's a bit kind of like
blinking you'll miss it in terms of the
working okay
so here comes method two um what i think
is a bit tricky about this question and
one of the things that confused people
was just it's all algebraic right so
you've got m's and n's and you don't
know what any of these numbers are so
you just kind of have to sift out those
pronumerals from the vector pronumerals
and then there's like more than one way
to say the vectors like ob versus little
b and all that kind of thing right so um
one of the things that is always helpful
particularly in proof questions um but
vector questions it's the same
is if the
pronun rules are sort of like weeding
you out flipping you out right then
we'll get rid of the pronumerals and see
if you can employ some reasoning that
will help you understand the situation
and then bring that back into the
pronumeral world so let me give you an
example of this right
what we've got here um is kind of like a
version a simplified numerical version
of the situation we've got okay so
there's this uh interval a b and it's
been divided up with this point c right
and we're told that there's a ratio
between them so what i've done is
something very similar here right i've
got some um interval and it's been
divided up in the middle and then i've
just designated some numbers here rather
than m
and n which are just a teeny bit
abstract from my
teeny little brain here and i've decided
well okay can i reason through this and
use that logic to help me when i do
introduce the pranium rules right
so the first thing you can all see is
that if i've broken this up in the ratio
of two to five right what that tells you
is that the whole thing there is going
to represent seven units of some kind
now the reason why that's helpful is
because you can then state you know you
can see here ac is from the start sort
of to that
not midway it's not a midpoint but
however far along c is i can think about
from the start this is equivalent to a
right over to that sort of you know part
way along i can think about pr as a
proportion
of pq right
what proportion is it well in this case
it's pretty clear to see that pr
is 2 7
2 7
of the entire interval p q right 2 over
7
p
q and that's because um the direction is
the same and just this constant
coefficient tells you how far along you
go this kind of yardstick as it were
so how do i bring this into
our our pronumeral unknown kind of
situation here right well this is the
relationship we've been told in this
situation i don't have a pq and an r
i've got an a b and a c
if you're told that c b on ac
is m over n which one is m
and which one is n you just have to be a
teeny bit careful here right
you just compare
across the numerators and you compare
across the denominators this is going to
be m
and this is going to be n which is
slightly dicey because like hey hold on
a second it's like it's right to left
instead of left to right okay but that's
one of the things that we're looking for
here so if that's the case you can see
likewise down the bottom i got that 7 by
adding the two proportions so it's just
going to be m plus m
now the reason why this is useful is
because now i can say i can go directly
to saying ac is equal to this thing
related to the whole a b vector right
it's going to be instead of two over
seven it's this length which was the two
before over
this length which was the seven before
the entire interval multiplied by a b
do you agree with that like it's that
that proportion of the entire interval
and from here like i said just kind of
blinking your misser what is a b um one
of the definitions we have for it is
it's the it's b minus a right in in
lowercase notation um if you're a little
suspect of that because you're like mr
ruby there's two whole marks here okay
is this going to be enough number one
this diagram here is doing a lot of the
reasoning for us but number two if
you're still a bit paranoid that you're
like mr wu will i get full marks for
this then we just tease out just a teeny
little bit just to make it more obvious
and i think it's a lot easier to do like
you don't need any of the
um the sophisticated
substitution rearrangement that we're
doing here it's much simpler if we think
about it in this case here um i've got n
on m plus n out the front and ao by
definition is minus o a i'm just going
backwards along the vector and so you
can see here is the little b and here's
the minus little a right so i'm very
satisfied to just put it there not only
is this less lines of working but i
would say that each of the lines of
working is instrumentally easier to do
right like it's pretty straightforward
working okay
all right so um that was part one i
promised i would show you two ways um
part two is quite routine so i'm gonna
do it real quick and then i'm gonna send
you into breakouts to have a go at part
three together okay so here's this
result it's just the one mark so it's
not meant to be arduous so here's the
proof i'm thinking about oc right how do
i get from o to c using the results that
i've already gotten so far well
you can see there's this c component
well i just proved that this is a c
right so clearly the relationship to get
oc and use this along the way
the most obvious way to do that is go
from o to a and then go from a to c
which is allows me to use the part one
result right
so that's going to be little a that's
going to be this
which i just got from the result above
i should say that from
part one
and then from here it's just a matter of
like expanding the brackets and slicing
and dicing right i'll get them on the
same m plus n denominator which is m
a plus n
a
all over
n plus n i hope you can see that that
first fraction is just equivalent to the
little a
i'll expand this while i'm at it so that
gives me an n b minus an n
a and that's all divided by the same
denominator
and then you just get some nice
cancelling happening right you can see
this minus n a and this plus n a they're
going to go
and that leaves me with if i separate
out
this this term here and this term here
it's
pretty much exactly what you need right
there's the m on m plus n out the front
lots of that a vector and then there's
the n
on m plus and
lots of the b vector as required
so that's why you can see it's just
worth the one mark